david dobrik by the way we talked about
this talking about puzzles and games
david dober came up with a game called a
hundred thousand dollar puzzle
he sold 17 000 of them in an hour
and people that buy the game can win up
to a hundred thousand dollars
he didn't sell a board he's he's selling
gambling he's just selling lotto tickets
you made a great point he really is like
the willy wonka for poor people
come with me and you'll see
i mean like give like i'll give you give
them porsches or something
he shows up with lambos occasionally
yeah look
i don't even know if he's a good guy
yeah here's the thing it's the last
thing you want to give to someone who
isn't financially stable
and like financially literate with mine
like like someone who's actually like in
the grips of poverty there's things you
have to work really seriously
yeah like do you think they let them
keep the cars or like right after the
cameras are off somebody comes in and
takes the car and the guy's like what
they go you knew what this was
you know what do you think you're being
given here's your appearance yeah yeah
he was 250 but there's something funny
about like
this whole thing whether it's him or
jeffree star and i've talked about it on
the show before
this idea of youtube philanthropy like
these guys
and the way that they are like a lot of
they they're just like
hey i'll hit your venmo and it's so sad
watching people on twitter be like
listen you know
my wife is out of work she just had an
operation i've covered i can't really
and it's so sad they're like tweeting at
these big people to pay their bills it's
[ __ ]
terrible and what's so sad is there's
like i'll see that but
also in that same fee people i knew from
comedy going
hey me and my roommate really we lost
our waitressing job
sort of and we we we really use help
with the rent
it's just like it's just the stacking of
like because yeah
you can't vet these people so it's just
no i mean that's why
it's so devastating to watch and sad
and it's also like a lot of these people
no one quite knows why they have money
like nobody knows why david dope like we
all know why but nobody
know like i'm confused right as to why
he has
the amount of money he does yeah but he
probably doesn't
no he does how much money does he have
what are 10 million or something right
oh so
10 million is not enough to be giving
away lambos though well they spot
companies sponsoring and they get they
buy the car that's what this is
okay that's my point yeah what does he
have
you have 15 million she's a lamb he's a
flambeau he's a lambo salesman
you sell slam you're a lambo advertiser
and listen good for
whatever but he made the money you know
he gets a lot of views
and stuff like that he's not looking but
you watch it
and you go i don't i i don't get it but
it's not for me to get here's the thing
when i don't hate the guy
it's a good grift whatever but you go
he's bringing more positivity into the
world that would be otherwise i don't
know if he is it's just
it's just weird it's it's it's it's it's
always this weird grift where it's just
like
who's just actually helping you probably
like the lotto
the amount of people who get lotto like
when they win big and just completely
[ __ ] up there's a certain amount of
success which i'll probably never reach
where you just have to start saying
things like
look under your seat like there's a
certain amount of money where people
just expect you to give them things
right
no matter what they're like okay i'm
gonna go get a free like water fan if i
if i sit through two hours of oprah like
that was a big thing oprah started it
like
look under your seat then ellen did it
and they give everybody like
there's just a certain amount of money
wherever you whenever you hit that
amount of money people expect you to
just walk around
and give them [ __ ] yeah this is kind of
thing you should do when you're a
criminal
right like a legit like mob boss yeah
like right
you're just buying loyalty from people
ellen should have given those cars to
her staff who she beat the [ __ ] out
yeah give them to the people that are
genuinely hurting people
yeah yeah and it's always you look at
people in the audience at eleanor oprah
and you go there couldn't be anyone less
deserving
than these middle class pieces of [ __ ]
upper middle class
have nothing to do but watch a
television when i was broke
i there was nothing less important than
going to watch a
tv taping right like the idea that like
anyone in that position needs anything
other than more work
like it should be look under your desk
there's more work for you to do
don't come back to this [ __ ] studio
to watch me interview
kirsten bell kristen bell or whoever
yeah the [ __ ] ellen's talking to
but yeah it's interesting the dobrik
game what did you find anything about it
it's it's
about how much he won so he profited
about 350 000
so he made 350 grand but yeah but a lot
of it's a lot of games to sell in an
hour that's why we need a product right
we can't keep [ __ ] right
entertainment man
you you know [ __ ] you could you could
really go
scratch that's why what about something
you could [ __ ] you know
i'm listening like a furby that like
like because the flashlight was too big
and it's just too gross
you it doesn't look like a living thing
you need like a like a free or own
version of a furby
like but it's like maybe uh you know
a face like a non what about a furby
with a very small mouth for pedophiles
look i mean it's better if they're doing
that than if you're you know with tiz
and that's exactly what we'll say
sure like a a small mouth
for a pedophile to face [ __ ]
why are you pushing back i just don't
know if we should lead with that look
pedophiles are
nothing else resourceful they'll figure
it out like
they'll share it on there before i don't
want them to understand i don't know but
we do
because we don't want them to [ __ ] the
actual kids fine but fine but i don't
know if we need to like come out in in
the advertising in the press conference
and so let's just say it's a child's
doll but for a million other things well
the dildos that women use are massagers
right right yeah sure
yeah this is it to practice if your
child falls in the pool
giving him giving him uh chest
compressions and mouth to mouth
this is this is problematic this is
complicated
my agent calls me he's like huh lakeith
stanfeld
sees you a pedophile dog and thinks it's
great
now he doesn't want to go into business
with you immediately but
just keep in mind that lakeith stefan
thinks you're a pedophile doll he's
great oh you guys been paying for me
oh [ __ ] yes that's right
somebody at danny mcbride's company who
is a pedophile
is really likes it doesn't want to say
who it is they sent us a message to
discord that they really like to doll
i mean could yeah i don't even want to
like you know keep this going but like
you could have a thing where like
probably only kids would wear it so it's
not good but you'd like
would it be a [ __ ] thing that you
could wear but you also [ __ ]
but then it should be the thing that
kids were in high schools i mean let me
get in trouble for it
yeah we don't want to get in trouble
those bracelets the kids used to
there's a little snack bracelets number
of staffordshire
snap razors yeah where you would snap it
on your wrist like
you remember ben wow because we got cut
because there's a metal thing in there
and they were like yeah and then there
were pogs i had pogs
i had o.j uh o.j slammer was your
simpsons slammer yeah
wow it said keep those out of the
slammer or something
and the back of it had a picture like an
engraving of a gun to his phone
and i remember more recently was the
fidget spinner i never had those
i didn't care but apparently they were
like a thing and then now they're
nothing
no they're nothing yeah like for like a
year there everyone was claiming to be
like
ocd maniac who like had to like [ __ ]
the whole time be honking 15 different
things
right you see these advanced fidget
spinners they have like knobs and like
grounds and gears
these youtubers go i like this i have to
fiddle with things
like it's i love to think you could show
somebody a picture like you go
go back in history you show somebody a
picture of the future you see all these
people fidgeting with all these things
like oh what are all these gadgets
it's like oh nothing they're just
they're just for something
for people to do that are on too many
ssris to get their dick cards so they
just want to play with a [ __ ]
weird [ __ ]